du coup les c'est ça mais aussi ça et
pour le réussir vous avez besoin de ça
plutôt que de ça ça peut être sucré et
salé
pour moi c'est une texture avant tout
bon samedi dans le moule coulis donc
faut que ça coule un coulis ce n'est ni
une purée ni une sauce ça se trouve
juste entre les deux si on parle d'un
coulis de tomate ce qui est arrivé cool
il est plus classe et qu'on peut avoir
ça va être vraiment quelque chose de
lisse leslie mais disons que c'est
toujours le point de commencer avec un
petit peu d'ail
je mettrai les tomates que j'aurais fait
et goûter ensuite la cuisson rapide soit
en qui est plus trop de liquide de mai
quand même que ne soyez pas tellement
comme saic sécher puis ensuite on va
aller le passé au moulin à légumes
tout simplement pour avoir une bonne
direction si jamais la taxe ne peut pas
être un peu toujours avec un petit
maquis de l'eau pour aller qu'on pensait
donc que je reviens de chercher là que
de ma fille à la garderie jeu par un
omnium et montclus tomate cuisse 5 10
minutes
or des pâtes et voilà c'est fait donc ça
peut vraiment être une bonne base pour
aller rapidement cuisine et après aussi
belle façon de conserver un surplus de
légumes comme ces poivrons de l'été
dernier si je penserai à d'autres
coulisses allez je pourrais faire un
coulis de tomates poivrons courge
pourquoi pas carottes dans le fond de
briguer le purée de légumes qu'on a
envie de détendre un peu dans une
pipette puis ensuite d'y aller ça sert
aussi de décoration ça nous permet de
dire un peu comme comme chef de pouvoir
aller faire des petits dessins et puis
des petites des petites créations un peu
plus coloré
je voulais aussi de montrer un peu la
versatilité du coulis par rapport salé
sucré nous hissions faire un flan de
france confie ça avec de petits colis de
paume est donc ça c'est pas le côté
sucré nécessairement que malek le parle
de ce côté à s'isoler un peu fruité qui
va aller faire ce que je veux je te
regarde un peu là la versatilité du
coulis pour les coolies sucré c'est
geneviève leclerc pâtissière de la
petite charlotte qu'on a gardé pour le
dessert en ce moment j'ai des framboises
fraîches mais
moi ce que j'ai
j'aime proposer aux gens c'est les
fruits congelés ont souvent honte on
achète un casque bleu et un spécial il
roule même on mangeait dessus puis finit
par sécher dans le frigidaire
si on les congèle et dégage de l'eau
dans son cas comme des germes fait que
tout ça se fait super bien sur le feu
par exemple sont pas le fruit on va tuer
puis on veut passer au tamis et surtout
celle des petites graines ont vraiment
rendu à l'iss les 6 puis on allonge avec
eux les fruits on n'est même pas obligé
de l'allonger mais pourquoi pas avec un
peu de crème afin comme pour les légumes
belle façon d'utiliser des fruits mont
joli puis un coulis on a souvent
tendance à penser aux framboises aux
fraises c'est comme des classiques qui
reviennent souvent mais pourquoi pas à
utiliser d'autres fruité coulis
d'abricot de la mangue et n'importe quoi
et on peut aller beaucoup plus loin pour
ajouter de la balise de l'as béziers
alors on va faire un mariage ici ma foi
qui me semble très heureux mais attendez
je fous des brownies précision même qui
coulisse ça s'est fait de quelle façon
en fait j'ai fait chauffer de la craie
en main que j'ai juste le sud nous
coulisses aurait dépassé de chocolat on
met un peu de beurre vraiment pour la
texture la queue
le vent va rajouter un petit extra mai
c'est tout je me laisse à lille ça coule
comme
ça veut couler de se reprendre celui sur
les déçus qui en ait plus pour le
dessert ou le petit déjeuner voici une
autre belle idée qu'est ce qu'on a ici
mimosas sas et coulis de base d'arachide
qui est en fait peut-être asiatiques
-les absolument le tir en force avec les
dumplings ces trucs là mais pourquoi pas
ici j'ai une banane à un déjeuner ou
même sur des crêpes une le matin golf la
place de juste à les étendre tartiner du
bar des pneus sur notre fameuse tôt le
matin mais là on oublier le pain pour
une voix vraiment directement avec la
banane
il avait beaucoup plu santé on peut même
aller mettre du granulat par dessus et
puis le mariage banane beurre d'arachide
c'est très bon s'est fait comme un
parent avec cette texture écoute c'est
carrément du beurre d'arachide est
acheté comme ça à l'épicerie on rajoute
un peu d'huile puis de le retrouver
on aurait en région fait d'enfants pour
convenir ouais si c'est
à voir oui c'est même d'ailleurs parce
que la texture et moins avec le côté
lisse du beurre d'arachide avec la
banane fonctionne très très bon
[Musique]